[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie this is gonna
be my video for all the Thor deleted
scenes and alternate endings there were
so many things that they changed during
the infinity war process a lot of those
things were specific to the Thor
storyline because he was so integral to
the overarching plot of infinity war
we're doing a new round of that IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so top ten
style starting with number 10 obviously
I think I've talked about this before
Loki survives
Thanos attack at the beginning he still
gets the space stone Thor still gets his
ass handed to him and half of the
Asgardians wind up dead but the other
half get away with Valkyrie and Korg
nine he rocket and Groot always pair off
to go to nineveh Lear to get his
Stormbreaker weapon but this is really
where some of the biggest changes start
happening the Russos in the writers of
the movie actually specifically
addressed this during the movie
commentary here's like a brief clip of
that ancient dwarves an ancient race of
weapons makers we struggled a lot as to
where this axe was gonna be if you
remember
and again I've been saying it and it's
like I forget every movie but every
scene needs to do more than one thing
and so we had scenes where it was
trapped by the basically a dragon I mean
all sorts of things but this scene not
only does it provide a test for Thor but
it also shows what Fanus has wrought
right and that's the second element that
you get you a little myth about the
forging of the gauntlet and that he's a
ruthless sob and I don't know why it
took us so long to figure out that he
needed to do that no it was such a
breeze a huge breakthrough was I took us
a long time to figure out how to design
this Dyson Sphere and the Forge and how
it would work there's a lot of
conceptual art created to figure it out
kept refining the rules in post as we're
developing the VFX and it almost cost
him his life and in doing so allows for
another character to make basically the
only choice he makes in the movie yeah
there's something very satisfying it
that from here on out
Thor's axe will have a little bit of
group
like that that really represents this
cross-pollination the we all know if
you've seen Thor that these weapons have
a healing power friends guardians as you
can tell there were a lot of crazy ideas
that they just shouted out they're
actually pretty cool sounding but for
budgetary reasons for story reasons just
didn't wind up making the final cut so
eight in the original version of events
Thor gets ultimate Thor's costume and he
still has long hair
they were always gonna give him a
version of ultimate Thor's hammer which
is still called Mjolnir but they had
envisioned him being the ultimate Thor
from the comics so he looked exactly
like that but obviously at the end of
Thor Ragnarok Taika Waititi cut Thor's
hair thank you very much Stan Lee and
give him that black version of the
costume that he wore throughout infinity
war so they weren't able to do a
straight-up comic-book ultimate Thor but
the next best thing
7 they also toyed with a white costume
that seems very similar to the Avengers
4 armor we've been seeing at all the
concept art the past couple of months
and that toy box art which might not
make it into Avengers 4 but it's also
possible this is also one of those
instances where they probably didn't
want to double down they were already
changing so many things about his
character they want to save something
for Avengers 4 so regardless of what his
new costume looks like in Avengers 4
this was what it was originally going to
look like in infinity war but six like I
said during that little commentary clip
there when Thor rocket and Groot
originally arrived on nineveh Lear they
find the forges had all been destroyed
by Thanos after each remade the Infinity
Gauntlet for him instead of just
chopping his hands off and deactivating
the star they drew their power from but
the big thing here is is that Thor
searches through the rubble of the
forges in fine Stormbreaker that way
instead of them straight-up forging it
also 5 the space dragon that they
mentioned the writers say that there was
a version of the movie where a dragon
forges Stormbreaker for Thor instead of
Eitri that sounds like an expensive
upgrade space dragon does sound really
really cool but the only dragon that
comes to mind when you're thinking oh I
want to see this in a movie is fing Fang
Foom and how do you explain him showing
up in the Dwarven homeworld as a weapon
Smith so it just didn't make a lot of
sense and it was really expensive on top
of a already very expensive movie for
they had a whole bunch of different
designs for the actual Stormbreaker
weapon I think they made the right call
they wanted it to
feel like the ultimate version of MCU
Mjolnir in the MCU version of the hammer
is just a little bit different from the
comic book version of the hammer but it
always has the ability to open the
Bifrost wormholes its strength level
compared to Mjolnir was always the same
so all the cool stuff about it was
always going to be what you saw during
the movie 3 getting into the alternate
endings so originally during the final
fight against Thanos when he had his
cool entrance and shows up and people
are all surprised that was originally
supposed to be a different character
showing up the ruse is revealed that
originally they wanted the surprise
entrance to be Captain America and for
it to happen when Thanos is running that
Avengers gauntlet so that trailer shot
that they put in every single trailer of
him running up and catching the Infinity
Gauntlet and screaming at the end of his
face that was gonna be the first time
that you saw Captain America during
infinity war after him showing up in
civil war like his beard everything you
were gonna get that all in the same
moment pretty easy to understand why
they changed that they didn't want to
make you wait more than two hours to see
Captain America for the first time since
civil war and if they had done that he
would have only been in the movie for a
couple minutes because relatively
quickly after that
Thanos snap sure's everyone and the
movies over but to Thor was always going
to come to Wakanda but instead of Thanos
Thresher machines chewing through
everything in their path Thor in rocket
have to fight the Midgard serpent or at
least the MCU version of the Midgard
serpent if you've been following Marvel
movie rumors since at least phase 2
there was a rumour during Thor the dark
world that Midgard serpent was going to
be a character that was going to have
something to do with the location of the
aether obviously that wound up changing
so a lot of times they'll have really
cool concept ideas that they'll just
save for future movies this looks like
maybe Midgard serpent is gonna get
pushed to some other future movie as
crazy awesome as that would have been
you have to imagine it would have been a
version of that guardians of the galaxy
to fight where they're on the platform
going against the appleís with Drax
jumping down his gullet you have to
imagine Thor doing a version of that
jumping down the Midgard serpent gullet
and killing it from the inside with
Stormbreaker
but number one the Avengers dogpile was
going to be the end of that gauntlet
that Thanos ran so you have to imagine
that they're all going at him at the
same time instead of one at a time Thor
still throw Stormbreaker into his chest
should have gone for the head
everyone's on top of him he's able to
free his gauntlet hand snap his fingers
and that's the end of everything and
then the end of the movie is relatively
similar with them just sitting there not
understanding what everyone's
disappearing there been a lot of you
that have asked about the Rousseau
special Q&A screening of infinity war
next week they're screening the movie
and doing a special Q&A because it's the
one-year anniversary of the release of
the infinity war trailer we're all
hoping the Disney is going to try and
use that anniversary to also drop the
Avengers 4 trailer if they do or if they
talk about anything during the Q&A then
I will totally make a video about it
this scenario will have a better picture
for when things are actually going to
start rolling out but don't forget
there's a prequel comic book for
Avengers 4 that they're releasing the
first week in December and why would
they release that prequel comic book
talking about the story if they weren't
gonna also start marketing the movie so
don't worry if you don't see the
Avengers 4 trailer next week it's still
happening before the end of the year per
Kevin Feige as comments make sure to let
me know in the comments what you want my
next Marvel video to be about
congratulations
Jasmine Lawson you're the giveaway
winner from my last big Marvel video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here for the brand-new
Captain Marvel trailer and click here
for a brand new Rick and Morty deleted
scenes thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you